ce voyage dans l'aviation et dans
l'espace des années 2000 ce sont des
projets fous aujourd'hui encore dans les
ordinateurs des constructeurs du monde
entier comme cet énorme airbus imaginer
un à 3,40 sur le dos d'un 747 en encore
plus large c'est la 3 xx trois étages
plus de 600 passagers un véritable
paquebot du ciel le jumbo des européens
pour les années 2003
encore plus fou ce cyber avions de
dassault systèmes à l'avion virtuel
c'est à dire un avion qui n'existe pas
dans la réalité pourtant incroyable on
peut se faufiler dans les diverses
canalisations comme si on était du
kérosène de l'air conditionné ou du
liquide hydraulique
en plus on peut visiter le poste de
pilotage ou la cabine pendant toute la
phase de conception
tous les ingénieurs peuvent travailler
en parallèle sur des pièces virtuelles
les modifier en parallèle voir les
impacts de leurs modifications et même
mieux prévoir tous les séquences mende
opérations de fabrication et la
maintenance de l'avion a posteriori
alors qu'il n'ya pas encore une seule
pièce physiques existent en matière
spatiale l'an 2000 c'est ce premier
élément russe présent au bourget de la
future station internationale iss un
immense mécano de 450 tonnes qui
demandera des années pour être
construits
et puis le bourget et concorde c'est une
histoire d'amour qui a commencé il ya
près de 30 ans un avion aux performances
techniques toujours inégalé et qui
aujourd'hui encore continue à étonner le
monde entier concorde présent toute la
journée de demain au bourget un avion
d'une éternelle jeunesse qui lui aussi
volera bientôt là de l'an 2000